[Music]
we're on the set
the musical episode is happening how are
you
how are you feeling i feel like i've won
a competition i was like please can i
one day sing and dance in something
that's really great i'm having a time in
my life yeah i cannot wait for people to
see this episode
i know you guys recorded all your own
vocals kind of walk us through the
process
of what has gone into this episode well
it's been a long time in the planning
actually because yeah
it's been muted around since we've done
like we've done a lot of music in the
show we did some dancing in the show
last season then people like are you
ever gonna do a musical episode
this being our final season it was
quietly on my bucket list as well i
think but we always wanted to find
a way to do it where it wasn't just oh
we're doing a musical episode there
needed to be a reason
for the music and the dancing to happen
which is god which is god indeed it
turns out when you've got god on your
show you can pretty much do whatever you
want
it's great i mean how has that
been i'm hearing that he sort of is the
puppeteer of this episode
yeah yeah so basically um dad comes to
visit
um because his children aren't getting
on uh and basically god comes down to
sorts out and he decides he's gonna stay
for a while much to you know
um lucifer's dismay and then um he
decides he's gonna follow his son around
and
he thinks it's just quite fun it's like
one of god's sort of fancy moments where
he just kind of goes
i'm going to make everyone sing and
dance right now it's very good
why'd you keep doing this just leave me
alone dad
yeah um and it's so that's the sort of
progression through our through this
episode it goes on to become something
else as we find out later down the road
but
what do you mean i can't what am i
allowed to say
i'm no no i'm not saying anything that's
all i'm giving you
where are lucifer and god in this point
of time are they getting along do they
have issues they are they have
huge issues with huge unresolved issues
dad seems to be
um pretending that nothing you know
nothing's ever been wrong and whatever
which of course wins lucifer up and he
spends most of his time on his dad just
to keep away from him
and then he has a sort of revelatory
moment in this episode where he's like
maybe for the sake of other things in my
life i should try getting along with my
dad
are we going to get the god and the
lucifer duet yes we do
what do they sing am i allowed to say
that
it's a really lovely moment
and it's a song that a lot of people
know okay
uh i'll leave it at that for now do you
feel like there's a theme to all the
songs like are they all sort of
connected there was like certain songs
that came up when we knew what the
situation was
and for example the song we're doing
today is like we were desperate to get
this song and get
get it cleared and be able to use it
because it's so perfect we've got all
the songs we wanted
i mean from what i've heard i only with
lyric changes as well
lyric changes occasionally like what oh
i can't
no no you won't tell us any
in the first song that lives for sings
he drops a very important lyric from the
original song in order
for this song to be personal for him a
big guest star in this episode debbie
gibson
what was it like dame debbie
how was it to have her in the middle oh
my god it was amazing actually
basically she came and we did a song
together
and but let's just say it's in the
police station
yeah and god it was i mean she's
obviously an amazing singer and from my
boy
it's like kind of debbie gibson um but
she was the loveliest
and not only that she acts in it as well
and she's a great actress she's like a
guest part for the episode so the
the murderer is at a high school and she
is the mum of one of the high school
football players
he has been dancing all day a while
we're just gonna throw you into this
how is the dancing and the singing been
for you
great yeah moving on yeah no no no it's
even harder
it's been totally hard for me it's
really really hard this was an amazing
dance
i was going to say i saw the twirl out
there you twirled straight into this he
did a good twirl
it's been fun yeah yeah it's been
challenging and fun
where's decker star in this episode well
we've
we've hit a bit of a low before this
episode lucifer unfortunately has a bit
of a revelation
that he thinks that he is actually not
capable of love you know they've hit a
bit of a sticking point in their
relationship because he hasn't said
the magic words to her and now chloe
is kind of in a place where she
is a little past the heartbreak of that
but now kind of going you know no
i don't believe that i don't believe
that anyone is incapable of love and
especially not you and i know you well
so
that's sort of in the background of the
musical episode do you
feel like she wants to change him or
just show him that he is capable
and how does that sort of fit into where
the story is going from here
i would think that she believes that he
is absolutely capable of love and is
just trying her very best to
maybe convince him a bit but also try
and bring that out of him without
pressuring him
you know because yeah i have some dying
he's a very literal character
so he kind of like he finding the
difference between feeling something
and saying something about that feeling
is a very sort of difficult thing for
him so
chloe's been very patient with him at
the moment about the fact that you know
i know you feel the way you do
yeah but um i'm going to give you the
time to just come to that realization
yourself
after fans see this episode will they
have hope
for decker star i think so they probably
will actually
yeah okay because of lucifer's
breakthrough
with with that god and the communication
you know we're we're not great at
finding our
love but we are very good at
communicating
i'm always asking you you always give an
honest answer so i think that keeps the
fans going well they're really not
hiding anything too much from each other
i mean things might be a little messed
up but the
the love is there the word might not
be being said but the communication is
there and that i think that gives people
hope you're right
[Music]
we do have god in this episode and in
this
season does god approve of chloe
i think so i think so we haven't had any
disapproving yet uh he's been very
charming you actually have your first
meeting in this episode
i was here yeah first episode on the
field how does that happen like what
brings them together
well it's it's there is this crime scene
basically it then turns into
a flash mob okay and a whole music video
right
but can i say kind of this yeah you know
we've been giving spoilers away i'm not
happy with that
a little bit or is that with all of the
frustrations that chloe has with lucifer
and not being able to be loved and sort
of knowing about his background and
feeling a bit that
lucifer was uh abandoned and you know
rejected and sent down
and all that uh in this moment that
takes place on this field when chloe
meets god she kind of lets loose on god
and just lays into him a bit
telling him that she does not think he's
a good parent
and she gives him her two cents
so to speak and lucifer has never loved
her more than that moment because i
think she's going to do what everyone
does which is just go oh my god it's god
i love you you're brilliant
and she does the exact opposite and i'm
like
like someone understands me certainly
yeah how does he respond to that
oh god annoying in the most beautiful
classy god way i mean we are so lucky
with dennis aren't we because he's just
got this quality about him he's perfect
for this role they're so lovely full of
peace
all seemingly full of peace and just at
ease
which you know is really frustrating
when you're trying to get someone to
admit something god in trying to kind of
like understand and get closer to his
son
decides that um he's gonna just put his
powers to one side
and feel what it's like to be human so
he makes himself human
and then goes on an adventure with
lucifer that kind of just falls apart
the scenes
whilst he's human and then he can't
remember where he put his powers
okay and really the only time i've
needed help and gone directly to god for
help
he has just gone human it was amazing
because dennis had
all these opportunities to play
everything for the first time so there
was stuff that was written in the script
and there was other stuff
that we found on the day and it it it's
a really
it's a really funny episode but it's
also a really touching episode
it is our biggest episode we've ever
done this without a doubt there's a
pivotal moment at the end
i would suggest between god and lucifer
there's a little bit of um
there's a little bit of um a
breakthrough
so they're on the menu i'm not saying
that
i'm just saying it's a bit of a
breakthrough okay when
fans watch this episode how do you how
do you think they're gonna feel
i'm not saying that yeah i didn't see it
okay
but how do you think fans are gonna feel
when they watch this episode
i hope that they love it yeah and i
would say the people that love musical
theater
and musicals are going to absolutely
adore it yeah
you know it's been i mean it's nice
because there are lots of fun numbers in
this
in it but there's also a couple of
really heartfelt numbers that are like
proper teenagers like emotional moments
in what way
well uh in the state that our characters
are in
you know when the song comes up and and
then what the words of the song mean to
that character
we try to find you know some connection
rather than just being random songs are
you allowed to say this on youtube i did
say that the opening song is my favorite
song i've ever said on the show without
a doubt can i brag about you for a
second without giving anything away
go on then if you must
don't yeah go tom's in a difficult place
lucifer is in a difficult place and tom
uh goes into song and he played it for
me
yesterday the day before and i was in my
trailer just
you know crying at how beautiful the
recording is
and knowing the moment within the story
and i just brought tears to my eyes i
mean
it's absolutely touching and gorgeous um
saying so well with the correct kind of
you know you can feel
what he's feeling through your singing
and it's it's gorgeous
that's beautiful how do you feel hearing
that oh you know
no i'm i'm i'm not gonna lie i'm super
proud of
this whole episode actually and the way
everything's turned out but
this particular song is something that
i've wanted to do on the show for a
while
and we needed to find the right moment
and this is totally the right moment and
i'm just delighted with how it turned
out
you